No one's gonna pull a fast one on me
Cause I'll pull a fast one on you.
*GASP*
Ahh.. HEY!
It's like a sneeze intro...
Welcome back...
I'm playing, uh,  two episodes in one day
I'm only gonna play for 20 minutes, cause I don't have a lot of time.
That doesn't matter to you!!!
The point is that:
I'm really into playing this game
And I just wanna play more
And uh... Do my best!
....To give you guys the best quality content!
- that this channel is all about!!!!!!!
I forgot what we were doing..
...RIGHT!
The lant-The lantern...
Oh here it is!
....right?
The scale.
RIGHT?
Let's put the fUCKING LANTERN!
---AHHHH
ShutAAAP
Shatap...
I have a crazy idea.
Why don't you just fucking pull it down with the same weight?
Just like-Idk- I-I know, crazy right?
AH-OMG
IT'S A GATOR
sH00tR- I gotta k- I'm sorry Mr. Gator
Nu, Poods,plz, I am not the real gator..
stfu
I GOTTA KILL YA
What happened to you, Gator?
Great, I- I'm glad we did that.
Why is this room so extremely creepy....?
Hello?
There must be something in here
Hello??
What is up with this fucking room?
What was- Oh.
0-0
Shotgun!
BRING IT!
HELLO?!
I got a shotgun!
*GASP*
I'm not afraid to u-
Ohhhhh fuck nahhhh
Fuck nahh, man.....
I'm gonna heal
Yeh, I got HOLY WATER
And I got a SHOTGUN!
And I'M NOT AFR- Oh, god, it's black
I-I got scared of it, Jesus Christ
-And I'm NOT afraid to use it!
STFU
Ah. It's babies: It's fine
Hey, what u-
Nope, we got nothin'
Alright, we got a -(Hezitates)- BEAUTIFUL painting
Alright, that's...
-OHHH, it's Mr. Fuzbear!
How you doin', there?
'Hey, Pewdiepie!'
'Awhhhgh'
'OHH NOOO! PEWDIEPIE-UGhhh!!'
'Pewdiepie, you will die here' :)
Sht- GOD DAMN IT, TEDDY!
NO!
You will all die in here, even the audience of the Bros...
Well, that's just fucking weird.
Just sit in your chair n' shut the fuck upppp
That's my catchphrase
In this (wonderful) game
For some reason. (I wonder..)
Sh(DJ skills)Sh, Sh, Shut the fuck up.
HAH!
That's right!
No one's gonna pull a fast one on me, cuz I'll pull a fast one on you. (Is this a Deja vu? ;o )
*GASP*
WTF WAS THAT! Omg..
...*Sigh*
Let's not replay that, that was fucking pathetic. (I think it was hilarious)
Jeehzus Chri- ..STAHP
STAHP
JUST FUCKING STAHP
STAAAAAHP
Oh nowh..
Someone is upstairs
Something's wrong with her
No fuckin-
You fucking.. bitch
Bring it motherfucker..
YOU BEST BE NOT J-
This is fucking-
The creepiest part so far(I agree)
I swear to God
There's no looting or anything, it's just me fucking walking around
Wait, where'd I come from?
0-0
...Okay. (Yeah, let's get outta here)
Okay.(Mhm)
That can be arranged.
OH LOOK- There's bleach! Let's drink it! (I'm with chu)
'Hey bro!'
(Lol)
.....Why is the bleach talking to me?
Justabah-
Top of the morning to yah
This is- FUCK, why did I have to play the scariest part
-IN THE FUCKING NIGHT-AT NIGHT?!
A'ight, we got a house.
Oh, it's just the door. (Or was it? >:) )
Uhh
So this is a map, isn't it?
And that's a d- OH, it's a map of THIS room.
So there's something here.
Yeah, I see it.
Hey, look at that! (0.0 MAGIC!)
Okay (Kk.)
WOAH! What do we got here?!
-TOP O' THE MORN- OMG!
It's TATATATA (Jack, is that you?)
Lemme get your arm, buddy
Ah, it's fine.
Don't worry 'bout it (But...)
It's fine, just tear it up.
UGHHH (Told ya.)
UH!
Thanks Grandma!
You da best!
Hey.
Look, I told you it was moist. (Ew)
Oh god
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
*Chanting a curse on Grandma*
Bros, h-h-h-h-help me.. (YES PEWDS!)
Okay (Okay)
Oh god, it's too quiet-It's too fucking quiet.
It's too fuck-
-IT'S SAVING
OH MY GAWD (Nu I'm scared. Don't open the door)
*gASP* *SCREAM*
(Lel his face)
I'M TRYING TO HEADSHOT THIS MOTHERFUCKER BUT IT'S SO FUCKING BIG! (Wut?)
Stahp moving your head!
This is ridiculous
THANK YOU.
Those.. FUCKING MOIST MONSTERS, I HATE 'EM
I should've just drank the fucking bleach (And we would've died together)
Shut-
I just wanna go home
I don't wanna go home(But you just said...)
I wanna go home now
-Fuck.
Oh my GAWD
Lemme reload, motherfucker!
FUCK this fucking place!
Where the hell am I? (In hell :3)
I wanna go home so fucking bad
I KNOW MY AIM IS FUCKING TERRIBLE!
But it stresses me the fuck out
(Don't worry, Pewds, my aim is way worse ;-;)
NO, GATOR! (???)
Fuck, I don't fucking seeh where I'm going.
Oh, thank fucking gawd.
I'm fucking done with this place, man.
I don't know what to tell you..
Here you go..
So where do I get the.. So I got the arm..
How do I use the arm here?
I don't fu- AWW, FOR FUCK'S SAKE!
WHAT?!
WHAT!?
YES.
I GOT IT
RIGHT, I dunno who you are, but IIIIIIIIIIII I would love to-
What a fucking biatch.
Well, this has been great.
Alright, so we're heading back
To the trailer!
Because, uh.
I wanna fucking save.
WHA- FOR FUCK'S SAKE!!
GOD FUCKIN' DAMMIT
WHAAAT?!
NO
NO!
You're having a threesome without meh? (Df?)
OMG- I <3 activities!
Is it-eh
Great, great
Great talking to you, Isabella
It's always good fun!
It's always- (Alien singing)
Okay, so, uhh.
We go through all the family members.
It seems like.
I suppose WE are part of the family too.
And that's probably where the gift is coming from.
I think now we need the Crow keys.
So
I wanna make sure I have all this shit
Where IS the fridge?
Dere it ees.
This fridge wasn't-UHHH
COME ON, MAN
Whattafuuuuck
HEY! Look at that
Uh, The Pig is waiting.
For you-In the dissection room- Bitch >:c
Thanks, buddy! :D
-Appreciate it!
I'm starting to think I should invest in this one.
How much is it? Five
'Cause, my reloads are starting to get slow.
And we have five coins.
Fuck it.
'Life's handing you lemons, so take drugs."
Don't quote me on that.
I'm serious.
Okay, reloading speed increased.
Kewl.
The dissection room.
Where the fuck was that?
FUCK all the moist, man.
I fucking hate it.
Uhhh.
Hey, Moose, how you doin'?
Hey, good to see you too man
THERE it is.
Nice.
I've been looking for ya, Mr. Crow!
CAW CAW
Yeah good one, good one.
It works every- It works everytime buddy.
SUPPLY ROOM, MOTHAFUCKA!
YEAH!
Granade launchah
Shotgun shells.
ALL KINDS OF SHIT!
HELL YEAH!
Gunpowdah
What else ya got, buddy?
Can I break these? BOX! (Oh god)
Aw, I guess not.
BOX (NOT AGAIN)
Naw, okay.
Alright, Moose!
Top o' the morning to ya! *Kiss* (Aww, so cute. DON'T TELL MARZIA)
I'm heading back.
I think, uh, I'll do a save here.
And I'll see you tomorrow with another episode.
Although it'll be the same episode for you- (*HAND ATTACKS PEWDS*)
ALRIGHT! It's a new day-
-It's a new adventure.
Let's venture out TOGETHER.
Oh boi
It's gon' be a good time.
I miss Granny
Where's my bitch?
Mah main bitch.
I honestly- heh- This is a lil' embarrasing..
I don't remember..
Where I'm supposed to go-hoe..
Yeahhhhhhhhhh, okay
I'll just pretend that I know.
Uh... How am I doing so far?
-At pretending.
Out here! Of course! Of co-Of course!
The dissection room, wasn't it? (Yep)
Now where was-
..Shut the fuck up...
-the dissection room.
AH!!
The dissection room!
Down in the moist hole! I remember!
Ahh, my fav-my favourite place.
How's it going everyo-OH god
It's darker now, isn't it.
FUCK ME MAN
This ain't cool man.
Dis ain't cool at all, man..
It didn't use to be this dark!
I swear to god, man!
Fuck, man.
Awwhhghh
I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS! I HATE MOIST MONSTERS!
They're the fucking worse!
Oh god it's- Oh god bleach, lemme drink you, please (I want some too)
NO! Shut the fuck up!
And why are they making so much fucking sound? (That's what the neighbours said)
AHH!
GRANNY! GRANNY
I
ALMOST
SHOT
YOU!
Granny..
What are you doing here..?
Granny: 'Ahhh, I'm oldddd.'
Granny, I've got a fucking rocket launcher.
And I ain't nein afraid to using it.
'You wouldn't dare to shoot'
'You old pussy-
Okay you're right, Granny. (Phew)
It's time for you to go home.
Get a job. (She's too old, Pewds)
Get a job, Granny. (She'll die before she gets one)
'But I'm reti-" STFU
(...)
Alright, here we are.
There we go!
I wasted a bullet there, for no fucking reason, absolutely ever. (English please?)
RIGHT?
Oh, that sounds lovely.
(Unicorn language)
-Jacksepticeye
*sCREAMS*
WTF IS THAT
*Unicorn screams combined with 'NO, NO, NO, NO'
Uh, oh
Alright, we're gonna have to
-Do that. We're gonna have to do th-
BUT I SHOT HIS HEAD?!
IS IT DEAD YET?! (x2)
Ah, fuck, man. It was dead. I wasted ammo.
How's my ass-how's my health?
Not great. I've been better.
Alright, that's fine.
Fuck (x2)
Next time, I-I'll knife.
This place has a different feel to it, ya know.
It's not as nice in the dark
I gotta-I gotta say.
I don't like it. (Neither do I)
How's Depety doing?
Let's ch- HEY! Look, it's Depety.
*Reads the sign*
Uh..
Stfu.
Fine, I'll do it. (THAT EASY?!)
OHH MY GOD
Halo!
Snacky..(?!)
"Hope there's some Nutella down there."-Pewdiepie 2017.
I've done that before, if you know what I mean. >: )
SHNACKYY!
I got a shna-
STFU
ahfehsuduew-I hate it how they keep fucking flobbing!
oH, he's still alive... Fuck.
I don't wanna-
I'm just gonna run past this guy
Hey why don't you come in? Take a seat.
Take a seat.
OH WAIT
-I forgot. OMG
The famous- The famous flop attack.
*You're grounded now.* *Closes door*
You think about what you've done.
Alright, I should probably heal anyway.
Hopefully, no more ambushes is waiting for me.
I'm sure it's gonna be safe!
YOLO
Granny! GRANNY SAVE ME, GRANNY!
Granny! (x3)
FUCK!
What was that?!
What
was
that?!
Oh here it is- *Swedish*
I'mma close to the door, AND YOU BE NICE, YOU BE NICE
Fuck that place!
Fuck that fucking place man.
Why does the game get scarier..
I can't handle it.
Not a fan
SAVE STATION
GOTTA LOVE MAH SAVE STATION
Now let's do some shit! (No, Pewds, you do that in a toilet.)
Alright, let's.. HEAD ON NOW!
I know where the Snake Room is,
And I've already been up there a lil' bit.
It doesn't look- *Alien language combined with swedish and unicorn.*
Great!
NO!
WHAT THE HELL IS YOUR FUCKING PROBLE-
Omg
WTF
Okay, I need to man the fuck up.
Alright
I'm getting- I'm being too much of
a lil'- a lil' girl.
There we go. One shot
One kill
Great (x3), fantastic, see
I, uh, I, pfff
That was pretty cool, did you feel like I was being really cool there?
'Cause I didn't. Fuck this.
Here's the Snake Room key.
There's TWO Snake Room k- uh, doors.
So let's start with this one.
Maybe three, Idfk.
SHNEK ROOM
-GATOR!
How you doin' buddy?
'Ey, it's meh, the Subtitle Goddess'- I mean, "Hey, it's me, Gator.'
'You want a kiss'
'You want a kiss, Sir?"
Yes, yes, I would like!
Oh, my, but I.. *Pewds gives up on life*
Great.
It's broken.
Wha- Like my heart, Sir.
Okay, sorry, Gator.
This looks suspicious!!!
*Reads text*
GR8
Surely, there's something in here
that we need!
What about this trophy?
3rd place-PAH
*Makes fun of loser*
Alright, what else we got?
HEY! Shotgun shells in a kid's room.
Look at that! A BALL!
It's a ball.
STFU GATOR
But Sir, I did not say anything.
WUT!?
It wasn't there before!
Of course. Your observation skills are absolutely terrible, Sir. (Hmmmmmm)
Kk, alright.
I see how it is. (No you don't)
Let's go up, then.
I just wanna make sure I get ALL the poop I need.
There we go! See? See what I'm talking about?
Yes, Sir.
Good luck, Sir.
'I love you.' I love you too, Gator.
I love you too, bby.
One day, we'll run away together.
How do I get up there?
Oh fuck!
There's a bubble head right there!
Alright, fuck it. Let's just check the other rooms while we still can.
Where's the other snake room?
I SWEAR THERE'S A SHNA-
There it is.
I SWEAR THERE'S A SHNAKE ROOM!
*Pewds having deep thoughts about Shnake Rooms.*
Is it weird when I talk to you and you don't reply, but you think of a reply in your head?
That's right. Pewds know what you're doing, motherfucker.
GRANNY!
'H-hi.. You made it out o' that hole!'
Granny.
You look good.(AKA: You're hot asf. HEY, DON'T LOOK AT ME! Pewds said that)
You look damn good.
Lemme just- Ouhh... Nice.
SMOKING THEM HERBS, ARE WE GRANNY?
"Yeah, I'm in that dank shit!"
Alright granny.
Don't mind if I do.
Don't mind if I help myself out, ya know.
Uh, nod twice if you don't mind me taking your weed.
'I can't move'
Aww, well that's too bad, Granny. (;-;)
That's too bad. I tried to- I tried to help you.
HEY ____________!!!
Eggcelent
What a fucking shitty room you have here.
*Reads*
Alright, well that's how clocks fucking work, ya fucking idiot.
Hey, do you know if there's a.... Ahh, nevermind.
Hey, there's a box here.
Let's open it!
WOW!
I'll take it. I'll take a lockpick.
What else we got?
You stocking me up, Granny!
*Angelical singing*
HEY!
It's a treasure photo!
*Tries to explain like a pro*
Could I have been that stupid all along?
There was a mannequin head in the toilet.
Wut is this? Ouhh
Yeah, we already found it, luckily.
That's cool
OH! Fuck yeah! Can't believe I almost missed that.
Jeehzus Christ
Ok
That didn't even fucking help us, did it?
Maybe there's a way to get up there!
OH! What do we got?
Found it!
I tried to eh warn you Bros
*Gator language*
'You might get out..' I love you, Gator.
But I need to do my doodies. (?)
Let's go
Modafuka
Oh gawd
Well actually, this is not that creepy
HEY! It's a Christmas Tree..
Ya know, for an attic, this is not that bad.
Hey, and axe!
Alright! What do I need with it-
Oh my gawd
These black-Fucking-Mannequins scare the shit out of meh
Alright, we can play that in the trailer.
Conviniently, we just got more space.
Like, fuck.
We got some magazines..
OH!My favourite board game! Oh fishing.
It's... Oh, it's...  great.
Awhh, come on.
How am I so full of shit? (Oh, you need the toilet?)
Not the way you think I meant saying that. (Oh, nvm then.)
L-Look at my holding the knife
(AHH! OUR BELOVED PEWDIEPIE IS A STABBER!)
Field of view. It's a funny thing, isn't it.
Alright.
Idk why they bother with these puzzles, 'cause they're so fucking easy.
I have a feeling I'm gonna eat my words for dinner.
Nope.
There we go.     AXE MAN!!! Oh look!
Good. I'm tired of walking into secret fucking rooms.
Wut is dis
Okay we got one of the keycards.
FUCK! We're too full of shit!
Honestly!
I suppose I could take these. Oh, I have to make them with something.
FFS
Alright, cool, we got it.
I have a feeling something bad is waiting for me downstairs (Me too)
You know, everytime you progress, it's like.
"Hey, you progressed, good job! NOW FUCK YOU!"
"Hey, Sir Poods."
"Good luck on your adventures."
Thank you Gator
Alright then.
*Pewds trying to be cool.*
It would make sense
If I find another keycard.
In this room.
'Cause there's two Snake Rooms.
OH! Look at that. What did I say?
What did I say, huh? What did I say?
GRANNY! You son(?) of a bitch!
"Ahh... I hoped you wouldn't find it, you COCK SUCKA"
I'm dissapointed
Uh.. Alright. I will find it Granny.
Don't you fucking worry about it.
Alright
"YOU'LL NEVER FIND IT"
STFU GRANNY
You don't know me
Uh... Alright. So we just need to s- OH! So we need to set the time as the other clock.
Alright, so let me just look at the time... BIATCH
Uh... It's quarter past... ten.
Is that it? Are we rrrrright? Yeah.
Ahh. Fuck's sake.
(PEWDS STOP TALKING, AND CONCENTRATE!)
YEAHH THAT'S RIGHT, GRANNY! YOU WANNA JUMP IN, BATCH?
YOU TRY TO HIDE IT FROM ME, MOTHAFUCKA?!
Alright, down we go,
Oh god. (Oh no)
Oh fuck.
It's okay. I got a shotgun. (Aww, Pewds. Always positive.) I feel safe with this thing. No gonna lie.
How many fucking hidden rooms and shit do you need in a house?!
To be fair, it's kinda awesome, though.
Awhh, Jeesus Christ.
Granny was onto some weird-
Some weird hentai shit, man. (Lmao)
There's- Awh, I don't have enough space, dude! Honestly.
No, I'm not gonna w-
(Wait, finish the sentence dude)
(FINISH THE SENTENCE! No? Fine XD)
The Workshop.
Isn't it.
Alright, so the lovely, lovely workshop is here..
Fuck. This place made me so uneasy.
It's, uh..
Could it be the cow- cow legs?
Idk. There's a keycard.
Fuck yeah.
I wanna get every fucking bit of ammo that I can.
And I will.
Hey, look! It's Mr. Moose!
Ah, fuck you.
You just had to go for a final-
*Pewds insults the poor Mr. Monster.*
Close the door, close the door.
Hey, we're fine. Everything's fine.
RIGHT? hehehe.
Ah, fuck off, Zoe.
*Random person called Zoe gets triggered*
It's herb there.
No, you're an asshole.
OMG OKAY, WHAT?!
Yes.
In my pants. (LET'S TRASH THE PARTY!)
Oh, okay, courtyard.
EVERYBODY!
Jacksepticeye, Markiplier, EVERYBODY! (Yes, Pewds.)
Oh my gawd! I better hurry up!
Hohomg!
WTF U FUCKIN' ----- PIECE OF SHIT, WHERE THE FUCK DID YOU COME FROM?!
ASSHOLE!
God damn it!
Burn in hell motherfucker.
GR8! Now I wasted a bunch of fucking ammo- (PEWDS STOP COMPLAINING, ATLEAST YOU'RE ALIVE!)
*Pewds sniffes bra*
ALRIGHT! Now I'm ready. Back.
*Sings a song about the save station*
Oh, you can change ammo.
Alright, I'm just gonna open these fucking doors really quick.
Don't mind me.
Welcome to Par- THANK YOU TOILET!
Thank you for the warm welcoming!
Omg
Blue and red
HEY! How about that everybody.
*Imitates Jacksepticeye, fails*
Is there like a party down there?
Hell yeah
Alright. I've never been to a party before, I'm , I'm nervous.
Oh, now I remember. I wanted to play the VHS tape.
I hope I don't get to play it. I feel weird playing someone else, ya know.
You play- It's too many layers man.
Too many onions. (x2)
*Reading*
Fuck, we're definet-
Why?
Well, maybe 'cause I have hair and you're-
(Inaudible)
I'm not into this..
Great. Oh, fuck, I'm playing.
God damn it.
Hey, how you doin' b- Oh, wow, that's... Fuck this.
Fuck this.
This is JUST what I didn't want.
God fucking dammit.
Alright, what did he set up for me.
Fuck, man.
This is definetly getting fucking scarier.
By the- Omg a toilet. Thank god.
(Um, wow Pewds)
OMG IT'S- Ahh
Hihi, wut?
nuu... Naw...
No, i-
Oh wow, how nice. Oh, god dammit!
I suppose it's not lit, huh?
What's this? I suppose we gotta turn this somehow.
To make sure we solve the puzzle, right.
There's just a fucking rope in it.
What do we got here? HEY! It's a birthday party.
It's mah birthday.
Happy Birthday! (Uh.. Happy Bday?)
So I can lick that, potentionally get alot of shit.
Alright, well this is a good time. I'm having a great time.
I can lit them on the- Like that. Okay.
I just need a... Pipe or some shiteuh.
To solve this little puzzle.
I don't think I saw one. Unless there was one in te toilet
Great...great
You don't have to go so close to it.
What is that? An hourgla- A t-a telescope.
Df am I gonna do with-
Wow, amazing.
I see- I see everything now.
*Reads* -Okay.
Man, this is trickier than I though.
It's like onions, it's got layers.(Lol)
I can't stop saying that.
Just like I can't stop making Jacksepticeye references.
Um, maybe we can burn the rope? Let's try that.
I got a caaandleee!
Mudafukaa
*Keeps singing, then says: * Someone commented that the house may be infected aswell.
Because otherwise, it would've burnt down already.I don't know it it makes any fucking sense, but it was an interesting thought.
HEYY! BALLOONS!!!! *Goes crazy about balloons*
Hey, I found a balloon! I love balloons!
Let's just fucking pop them all motherfucker ballons *Goes crazy again*
Ah, fuck, I don't- *Tries to read*
But the password is 'Happy'
Fuck. Okay, then what is this then?
An uninflated rubber balloon.
Maybe we can put that on the gas?
Let's try that.
It's probably a message inside the balloon, once it pops or some god dammit key.
Light the candle
NO!!!
I guess that wouldn't work, would it?
I mean, I literally could just go like this, could I?
Really? I thought that would work.
No wait, that's not where the gas was, the gas was over here.
Oh, god. That's gonna hurt.
Yeah.
Definetly fucking sucked.
EWWW
Oh my gawd 0-0
Why did you- AHHH
Why didn't you take cover!? What the fuck.
You fucking asshole.
A quilt pen. Alright, that should probably fit this guy, right? Hey, you want a pen, buddy.
WUT? It won't hold it properly?
Well this game is just full of problems, isn't it?
What the hell man
Uhh, okay.
Do you have a password for me, or something like that?
Oh, I get it. Maybe we look through this.
How do I clean it? I obvio-Obviously need to clean it.
Uh, let's keep looking around. I-Pff.
Who knows, maybe we'll find something.
I feel like I have to try this, because it'll be so stupid if it works.
OH! It washes it! Look at that!
Cool! Oh, but it also gets the candle.
Alright. So now that we have- Ugh, fuck off.
Maybe now we could look here? 'Cause it does look like he would have the password.
Yeah, that doesn't help me at all, does it.
K, where would we look with the telescope?
Uh... Lot of puzzles. Lot of puzzles. We're doing alright though. I think we're doing okay.
I'm sure everyone's like "UGH WTF, WHY DON'T YOU DO THAT?!"
"Ugh, you fucking idiot, how can you not know how to play this game, even though you're playing it blindy."
"When I play games, I play them flawlessly, and I never make any mistakes."
"'Cause I know all the games."
Yeah, alright, alright, you said it buddy.
So we washed off the telescope. The question is: Where do we use the telescope?
I imagine we're gonna- Was that there before? Wut? Great.
"'It won't stop coming out.' Just like me when I'm in bed, am I right? " -Pewdiepie 2017
Okay, so now we have a winding key.
Wtf is this. Okay, guess not! Lovely walls.
Okay so.. Uh. We have.
Feather.
Winding key.
Where would we use a winding key? Would you like a winding key?
Maybe in the middle? OHH, alright.
Alright, what you got for me, uh, Mr. Clown. (Inaudible) How you doing buddy? You look good. Glad you did your face reveal.
Df was that? Was that all you did?
In suppose he will draw the password.
If he gets a hold of the hand.
But he can't fucking hold it. 'Cause it won't fit properly- He can't hold it properly.
So what can we make him-
Polerize- It'll fit it with a polerizing filter. (Wut?)
So something will show up if we use it at the right spot.
Did this image change? OH it changes!Oh, okay.
So.. Hang, whatever the fuck that is, and baby.
Okay. Alright! Heyy
I think I'm doing pretty good. I think I'm pretty- Okay, so, Hang.
Whatever the fuck THAT was..
That one... It's a bird on a bell, or some shit.
And... Baby.
Justin Bieber. (Baby, baby, baby, Ohh!)
There we go. HEY look at that.
It's Jacksepticeye!
A straw doll. FFS, can I get something that helps?
I'm enjoying these puzzles actually. It's a nice change of phase.
Fuck's sake. I don't... Can we combine?
"Hey Pewdiepies How-How's it going, there's a stick up my ass." (Um.. Pewds needs help.)
Df am I gonna do with this?
Seriously, it doesn't fit?
My gawd.
Alright, okay.. Running fucking low on ideas here..
Burn it? Really? Okay!
Burn, Jacksepticeye... (MOUHAHAHAH!)
Awhh, Yeah! Now OKAY! Cool! Hard to the touch.
Got it. Okay.
There you go, buddy. Well, FFS, you're supposed to hold the- God dammit, Cl- God- just- y- ahh.
There we go. There you go.
You're welcome
Give it a-
Ahhh! You creepy son of a bitch! Wtf.
I don't want a hive five- WOAH NO! What the fuck- NO! Ah, 'loser'.
You fuckin asshole!
God damn it, wtf ya bitch..
Oh my god
Alright, the password is 'Loser' gr8.
Where's the R? There we go.
HEYY! Hey, how's it going everybody?
*Pewds is so happy*
Gotta actually remove the fucking water thing. Lemme guess: When I solve the puzzle, I just fuckin' die anyways, so.
It's a good one , ain't it, when that happens. It's good. Good fun, good fun. It feels good, it feels great. Love it. 10/10. Best game.
Now, I don't have to be, uh, wet anymore.
When I piss myself, people will see it. (Df, Pewds.) God dammit.
Yay!
Happy fucking birthday.
Ahh jeez.
This guy is having  rough time.  Oh come on.
Awwhhh, dude... I wish I..
*Pewds shouting "NOOO!"*
*Panic*
What a sadistic fucking game.. Jesus Christ.
My gawd.
*Pewds thanking the crazy guy*
ALRIGHT! Well I'm gonna end that episode there! Next episode, we're gonna go and PARTY! YEAH!(YAY!)
Are you excited?
This game is fucked up. I'm loving all the support that I'm getting.. I keep saying it, but it still means alot to me. And, uh.. I'm having alot of fun sharing it online.
So thank you.. for watching it.. It means alot <3 And uh, I'll see you tomorrow! Stay awesome Bros.. (Buh-Bye!)